[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
WILL NITZE: So as Tom said,
I am a visiting entrepreneur.
I hail from Boston.
About a year ago, I founded
a company called IQ bar.
The basic one-sentence pitch
is, it's the first nutrition
bar optimized for the brain,
brain function, and brain
health.
And I was invited to give
a chat about really what
whatever I thought you guys
would find interesting.
My first thought
was maybe I'll talk
about the entrepreneurial
journey, the ups and downs,
the vicissitudes of
starting a food company.
But I think you guys
have a lot of exposure
to the ups and downs of
innovative businesses.
And so I thought it
would be probably more
interesting to talk to
you guys about something
that I think a lot
about on a daily basis,
but maybe you don't
get as much exposure
to, which is this linkage,
this intimate linkage
between the food we eat and our
most precious organ, the brain.
And so, a little bit more
background on myself.
I studied government, as well
as psych and neuroscience
as an undergrad at Harvard.
And during that time,
I became just totally
fascinated with
the brain, how it
works, how it fails,
how to optimize it,
how to make it work better.
However, I failed to identify
a professional outlet
for that passion.
And so, by default I ended up
taking a job in software, sales
and marketing, because I almost
didn't know what else to do.
And very quickly realized
that was not for me,
selling B2B supply chain and
op software to oil and gas
companies, as unsexy
as that sounds.
But quickly realized
that was not for me.
I didn't want to spend the
next 30 years doing that.
So concurrent to making
that realization,
I started experiencing
difficulties with my own brain.
So I was getting mental fatigue,
trouble focusing, headaches,
things like that
on a daily basis.
Basically, I just felt
terrible every late afternoon
of every day.
And pretty good, I identified
diet as the cause of that,
as the root cause of that.
And so my obsession
with the brain
expanded to include
nutrition, how
do I eat things that help
my brain function better
and help protect my
brain in the long run.
So I started just using
myself as a Guinea pig.
I self tested new dietary
trends, started voraciously
researching brain nutrition.
And pretty quickly, I was able
to ameliorate those symptoms
that I was experiencing.
And basically by transitioning
away from a Standard American
Diet, aka, SAD, I transitioned
to a much lower carb,
more paleo/keto--
just low carb in general diet.
Basically, I was eating lot
more fats, and a lot fewer
carbs, which was the inverse of
what I grew up eating and had
eaten for decades.
And everything got better.
But I quickly became
frustrated, because there just
aren't that many solutions
for someone like me.
I would have to make a salad
with 10 different components
to achieve the nutritional
goals I had for my brain.
And so that was crazy to me.
I was like how has
no one optimized
something for the brain.
And so I-- well,
actually, while I
was working in software,
on nights and on weekends,
I started developing
these products.
Ultimately I developed a minimum
viable product, quit my job,
and kind of went all in on that.
But that's just the
background on me.
That's not really what I'm
going to be talking about.
Today, I really want to discuss
three things predominantly.
The first one is the
problem, the micro problem
for, I'm sure, a
lot of you, for me,
and then just society
as a whole, which
is to redeem the broken
brain problem in America.
The second thing is
diet's relation to that.
How does diet
perpetuate that issue?
And why do we
consistently eat things
that are bad for
our brains, even
when we know that they're
bad for our brains.
And then the third
thing is just Q&A. So
you guys can feel free to ask
me about the slides I'm showing,
or about whatever you
want to ask about,
what it's like to
start a food company,
the ups and downs,
all that good stuff.
Feel free to ask any of that.
OK, so let's talk about
the problem and an overview
a few, frankly,
depressing stats.
So when we talk about
the broken brain problem,
it's really twofold.
There's a short-term
set of issues.
And then there's a
long-term set of issues.
So the short-term set of
issues is day-to-day issues.
Most of us feel terrible
at 2:30 or 3:00 PM.
So much so, that the 2:30 effect
has been coined as a phrase.
So three in four
American workers
feel mentally fatigued
most days of the week.
Most people are
mentally tired most
of the time, which is kind
of staggering to think about,
and has a bunch of implications.
Some of them are economic.
So that cost in the US, $140
billion in lost productivity.
But you guys probably
don't care as much
about that as the quality
of life implications.
So you just don't feel good.
You're not as sharp.
You gain weight, or you have
headaches, inflamed brain,
which causes depressed mood.
There's a whole host
of short-term issues
that just make your
day less enjoyable.
Now the long-term of that
is what happens when--
what happens when you eat
a brain unhealthy diet
for decades at a time?
Well, now we start seeing
disease proliferation.
So I'll talk about
two in particular,
diabetes and Alzheimer's.
And in a second,
I'll link the two.
So diabetes, if we
reverse back to 1980s,
was one fourth of
what it is now.
So it's quadrupled in
the last few decades,
and doubled by rate of diabetes.
So obviously, there
are more people.
But also, the rate of diabetes
is double what it was.
And when we look at
Alzheimer's, there
are roughly five million people
with Alzheimer's in the US.
That's said to be
16 million in 2050.
So it's going to triple in
the next couple of decades.
So why am I in the same
breath talking about diabetes
and Alzheimer's?
Well, it turns out that the
two are intimately linked.
So Alzheimer's is
actually called Type
3 diabetes now by many
doctors, nutritionists,
people in the health
and wellness space.
Because you're 10 to 15 times
more likely to get Alzheimer's
if you have diabetes.
So anyone who says there's no
link between food and cognition
is out to lunch,
no pun intended.
But so that's the broken
brain problem at a high level.
Now, how does diet
specifically relate to that?
So we'll rewind to your
fifth grade science class.
How do you produce energy?
Well, you eat food.
You break proteins down
into amino acids, fats
into fatty acids, and carbs
into glucose, blood glucose.
Now what happens if the balance
of that is in favor of carbs?
You're eating a
bunch of pizzas, say.
Well, your diet looks
kind of like that red line
you're seeing on the graph on
the left of the slide there.
Basically, you're mass
producing blood glucose.
Your body goes into crisis
mode, pumps insulin, the hormone
insulin, in your blood,
that ferries all that blood
glucose out into your cells.
Some of it turns into energy.
A lot of it turns into fat.
And then, the issue with
that is that insulin response
is an overcompensation.
So you basically drain your
body of that blood glucose.
And you feel terrible
like two hours later.
That's the sugar
crash in an essence.
And what happens if the net
balance is in the favor of fat?
Well, none of that happens.
Your energy is much more stable.
You don't mass produce insulin.
You don't crash.
None of that's controversial.
That's all well known phenomena.
What's a little bit
more controversial,
although I don't really
think it should be,
is the longer term
dietary implications.
There's a bunch of
longitudinal studies
that look at people who eat a
ton of carbs relative to fats
and what happens to their
brain, relative to folks
who eat a ton of fats
relative to carbs.
And they're many times
more likely to develop
neurodegenerative diseases.
I don't even fully understand
why that's so controversial.
I think probably
because it's still
a holdover of if you're
not eating carbs,
you're eating fats.
And fats have been
demonized for decades.
And people just aren't as
comfortable prescribing
a high fat diet.
So if we know that all
these bad things happen
to us on a daily basis
and over decades of time,
the question I think a
lot about is why aren't we
thinking more about
the foods that we're
eating as they relate to
the downstream impacts
on our brain?
Why does that not
even really register
when we decide what we're
eating for lunch, or even
at 2:00 AM on a Saturday night?
Why is that not registering?
Although, I'm sure
you can probably
determine why in
that latter case.
So I've thought
a lot about this.
And to me, there are
really five reasons why
this doesn't register to us.
I think the first reason
is that, quote, unquote,
experts aren't actually
experts, or continuously
discredit themselves.
The second thing is
our biology actually
doesn't incentivize us to
think about this stuff.
Culture doesn't incentivize us.
There are way too many
things on our mind
when we're trying to pick lunch.
And then we're
really, really good
at blaming things other than
food, when food in reality
is part of the problem.
So I'll go through each
of those one by one.
So experts aren't
actually experts.
So when we think about
health and wellness, who
is the paragon, who is
the person we go to,
or the average American goes to?
You go to your doctor, right?
It's not just when
you sprain your ankle,
it's preventative,
what can I eat
so I don't get sick later on.
The problem with that
is, doctors aren't really
experts on nutrition.
They take, on average,
they get 25 hours
of nutritional teachings
over the course
of four years of med school.
So basically, any
educated person
knows as much about
nutrition as your doctor,
barring your doctor going off
and doing a bunch of research
of his or her own.
So that's a problem.
So maybe if doctors aren't the
experts, maybe it's the FDA,
or maybe it's some sort
of governmental body.
It is, after all, the Food and
Drug Administration, right?
The problem with that is if they
change their mind every five
years and often
discredit themselves.
I mean, there are
countless examples.
These are just a few.
I don't know if
you guys remember.
I grew up in the early '90s.
Everything on the
grocery stores had
big, low-fat in bold letters,
and it's flying off shelves.
That was because the
government basically
equated fat consumption
with getting a heart attack
in the late '70s through '80s.
And so fat became this villain,
which it wasn't even before.
People used to eat butter,
high fat, dairy, and things
like that, liberally,
for a long time.
Until this governmental
directive basically said,
fat is bad, you're going
to get a heart attack
when you eat a lot of fat.
Now again, decades later,
diabetes is up four X,
the rate is up two X. So,
obviously, that was wrong.
And you know that's
wrong partially
because you don't see low-fat
on things like you used to.
Actually, in many cases,
it's the opposite.
Similar deal with eggs.
People freaked out that eggs
had a ton of cholesterol
and eggs were vilified.
If you're going to
eat eggs, you're
going to pack cholesterol
in your arteries.
You're going to
get heart failure.
Subsequently the FDA came
out, in 2015, and said,
actually, there's
really no evidence
that dietary cholesterol
correlates strongly
with blood cholesterol.
And so that high
blood cholesterol
wasn't really
because of your eggs.
It was because of other factors.
Similar deal with
salt. If you eat salt,
you're going to get super high
blood pressure and get sick.
And that was basically
discredited for a series
of studies, starting in 2013.
So experts aren't really
experts is the bottom line.
And that's a problem,
because where do you turn to.
And if there are
no real experts,
then I'll just eat
whatever is in front of me,
or what's served to
me, and I won't really
think about it that much.
The second problem is that
biology doesn't actually
incentivize us to eat
a brain healthy diet.
So this was really
perplexing to a lot
of people for a long time.
The question of
why, if our genes
are supposed to be mostly right,
why does sugar taste so good?
Why do I crave sugar?
Why is my body pushing me
to eat this if it's just
going to hurt my body?
And what most people
are netting out to now
is that if you reverse
hundreds of thousands,
millions of years,
early humans, there just
wasn't all that much food.
And so to survive,
you needed to eat
food that packed on fat, fatty
tissue, as much as you could.
Because you're not going to
get a meal the next week,
and you're going to have to
survive on your own body fat.
So it works really well
when food is really sparse,
eating like 15 apples.
But that works terribly
when you could get
another 15 apples the next day.
So our genes haven't caught
up the food abundant realities
of the modern era.
So the second
biological issue is
our brain doesn't have
any pain receptors.
You actually
literally don't know
when you're hurting your brain.
So you know if you
eat a bad oyster, that
hurts your stomach.
And you can see
dietary implications
in terms of weight gain
and weight loss, which
pain can be relevant to.
But you just don't feel
pain in your brain.
So you could have a chronically
inflamed brain over decades
and you would never know it.
And that's what most people
have in America, a chronically
inflamed brain.
And because you don't
have pain receptors,
you just don't know it.
There are other
downstream effects.
I feel tired and lethargic.
Well, that's not my brain.
That's just what happens
when you get older,
and you rationalize
it in some other way.
Another issue is that
culture does not incentivize
us to eat a brain healthy diet.
When we think about the body
parts as they relate to diet,
it's like I want washboard abs.
I want to look awesome
in my Instagram photo.
That's actually not all
that bad, necessarily,
because what's good for
your body health wise tends
to be good for your brain.
Where I think that's a
hugely missed opportunity
is that's just the baseline.
When you're eating for
your body or your abs,
rather than your
brain, you're not
layering on all the additional
things that could actually
enhance your cognitive function,
not drinking Lion's Mane tea,
or getting adequate amounts
of vitamin E, or magnesium,
or what have you,
a whole laundry
list of things you really
should be feeding your brain.
You're just focused on what's
my macro nutritional balance
that's going to
lead to a six pack.
So another issue
is, frankly, just--
I'm sure you guys have all
heard as American as apple pie,
right?
That's an American staple.
It turns out apple
pie, most apple pie's
are terrible for your brain.
But also, you just go
to any social gathering,
what are they serving?
They're serving pizza and beer.
You're throwing your
kid a birthday party.
It's a pizza party,
probably with soda.
So the American staples of
the American social gathering
are all highly carb centric
and terrible for your brain.
And that's really
hard to change.
A culture is going to be
one of the later things
to shift when we're looking
at all of these variables.
Frankly, I'm not that
optimistic about--
I'm not going to short
the pizza and beer market,
I'll put it that way.
Although, I might
short Papa John's
in light of recent developments.
But I think actually
the biggest issue here
is that there are frankly
too many variables that
drive food selection.
There are too many things
that cycle through our brain
when you reach to grab one
snack, or one meal, or another,
that we just can't
compute that many things.
And so we make bad decisions.
And let's just run
through eight of them.
Satiety, feeling full.
That's a baseline, I want to
survive, so I'm going to eat.
Proximity, that sandwich
on that table over there,
I'm just going to grab that
and eat that because it's
closest to me.
I want to satisfy my
taste buds' cravings.
I want to eat things
that make me happy.
Because we all associate
emotion with food.
I want that $80 French dinner
to feel like it was worth it.
I'm just going to eat
what my co-workers are
eating for lunch.
I don't have time to
make this fish dish.
I'm going to just
microwave this burrito.
Or the eighth is an
actual consideration
of what is this
doing to my body?
So there are a couple
of interesting things
about all of these variables.
The first thing
that's interesting
is that health is one of eight.
Now, these are all--
the weightings of these
will vary, I'm sure,
amongst all of you,
for anyone really.
But just the sheer fact that
it's one of eight things
is not good.
And by the way, a subset of
that brain consideration,
of that health consideration,
is brain health.
So again, we get back
to that Instagram issue.
You're eating for
health, but are you
eating for brain health?
You're missing out on all these
additional layers of nutrients.
And then, the embarrassing
fact, the embarrassing reality
of this is, what is the strong--
after satiety, after
surviving, what
is the strongest determinant
of food selection?
It's proximity, literally
what's in the kitchen, what's
sitting in front of me,
what did someone serve me.
So there have been a number
of studies around this.
And 65% to 70% of
people say they just
eat what's in front of them.
That's literally how
they choose food.
Again, can't really blame
them, because of the earlier
variables.
No one really told them
what's good for the brain.
Culture didn't tell them to
eat brain healthy things,
et cetera, et cetera.
So the last thing I
wanted to talk about
is we're really good
at not blaming food
for things we sort of
should blame food for,
at least partially.
So I'll run through
a couple of examples.
Number one, we should get
tired of 2:30 every day.
It actually turns out we do--
our biological clock is
such that we get drowsy
in the late afternoon.
That's a natural cycle.
But we totally
overestimate how strong
that phenomenon should be.
It should be a transient thing
that frankly you can power
through with a cup of coffee.
You shouldn't be sleeping
on your desk at 4:00 PM.
And you can't attribute that
to that biological clock.
That's almost certainly
attributable to that bowl
of pasta you ate at lunch.
So the second thing
is we very often,
when something goes wrong health
wise, we say that's genetic,
it's in my family.
My dad had a heart disease.
And so I'm more
likely to get it.
And that's true.
That it is true.
The problem with that is
it's only part of the story.
It's leaving out
this key variables.
So remember, I talked earlier
about Type 3 diabetes.
If you get diabetes, you're 10
to 15 times more likely to get
Alzheimer's.
That has nothing to
do with genetics.
That's a downstream impact
of your dietary choices
over decades of time.
So half of the reason you're
going to get Alzheimer's is
genetic.
But the other half is not.
It's lifestyle choices.
You choose to smoke, it's
your diet, et cetera.
It also leaves out the important
phenomenon of epigenetics.
I'm not sure whether
you're familiar with this.
You can literally change
your gene expressions.
So 70% of your genes that are
tied to health and wellness,
longevity, whether you get
sick, and when you die,
70% of those genes, you
can turn on and turn off
based on lifestyle choices.
How much you sleep, what you
eat, if you smoke or not.
People don't really know that.
They don't know that
their genes are malleable.
But they are.
Cognitive impairments
are just a part of aging.
As I got older, I should
start forgetting stuff.
That doesn't have
to be true actually.
Your brain is programmed
to work well until you die.
So Alzheimer's, Parkinson's,
any pathology is something
going wrong with that plan.
And us choosing lifestyle,
making lifestyle decisions that
are contradictory to what our
genes crave from a dietary,
sleep, social,
gratification standpoint,
contradicting
those genes desires
is what causes us
to have problems
and how our brains not operate
optimally at an older age.
And then there's mood disorders.
So I'm depressed or
anxious because there's
some sort of chemical
imbalance in my brain.
Well, this is really
still poorly understood.
But what we do know
is that diet actually
correlates really strongly
with certain mood outcomes.
So I can't tell you
exactly what makes
people anxious or depressed.
But I can tell you that
when people eat things
like flavonoids, or cocoa,
or green tea, or blueberries,
they are less likely
to get depressed,
or they're more likely to
ameliorate that depression
or anxiety.
People don't associate food with
mood as much as they should,
or at least with
bettering mood disorder.
OK, so there are
a couple dynamics
that really complicate things.
These are frankly things I
don't know the answer to,
but I think are interesting
to think about, and just
other reason why this
is a problem that
continues to get perpetuated.
So number one, I think a lot of
so-called experts in this space
tend to prescribe things as
if we're all the same person.
The reality is if I
eat a bowl of rice
and my girlfriend
eats a bowl of rice,
and then we take blood
glucose tests of our blood,
I could look like
I'm pre-diabetic,
and she could look like
nothing happened at all.
Everyone reacts differently
to all the macronutrients.
And so that could
mean I can't eat rice.
That could mean she could
eat rice all the time.
So platitudinous prescriptions
for certain dietary,
adhering to certain
dietary paths just
don't work wholesale.
There's also an
argument, frankly,
to be made for living
a little, right?
Like life isn't worth
living if I can't eat
pizza, that kind of thing.
And I actually think
that's a valid argument.
Although I don't think
it's that valid, because--
and I don't think it's that
valid for anecdotal reasons,
my own anecdotes included.
So if you-- and I would
recommend you try this--
let's say you drink
sweet tea every day
from like South Carolina.
And then you just
go cold turkey.
You start drinking
unsweetened iced tea.
It's going to suck.
It's going to taste
terrible for like a week.
And then it's going
to start tasting good.
And you're going to
take a sip of sweet tea
and it's going to
taste horrible.
Our bodies are incredibly good
at adapting to new dietary
adherences.
And I'm sure you guys,
if you drink a Coke now,
and you haven't drank
soda in 10 years,
you're like how did I used to
pound three of these a day?
Or at least that's what I did.
But there is an argument there.
There's an interesting
agricultural,
like how do we feed the
world debate here also.
This debate is relevant
to grass fed beef.
Grass fed beef is awesome
if you can pay for it.
But it's just not--
like all of America
would have to be grazing
land for everyone
to eat grass fed beef.
So that's awesome.
It's better for you, but
not everyone can eat it.
Same deal with, for instance,
the mass production of soy,
corn, other higher
glycemic products,
that we're really, really
good at producing a ton of
and feeding a lot
of people with,
but aren't actually that great
for the people we're feeding.
I don't know the answer to that.
That's just a dynamic
that complicates things.
There are economic realities.
It's more expensive
to buy an avocado
than it is to buy sweet corn.
I also don't know
the answer to that.
There's interesting
things thrown out
about what are we subsidizing?
Why do we need to
specifically subsidize
corn, versus this, versus that.
Again, I don't know
the answer to that.
But it is a reality.
It is cheaper to eat
at McDonald's and it
will be for a long time.
And then this last
point hearkens
back to what I was
talking about earlier.
There are no authorities.
The so-called authorities
keep changing their minds.
And I don't see that changing.
And to some extent,
that's a good thing.
Because that's the
whole nature of science,
is revising hypotheses.
But it's certainly
frustrating when
eggs are good for you versus
bad for you every five years.
And then I just wanted to end
by giving a nod to the fact
that diet is, of course,
only one piece of the puzzle.
So you can eat the most
brain healthy diet ever.
But if you aren't exercising
and aren't sleeping, frankly,
more importantly,
on the sleep front,
it's not going to
do much for you.
I think sleep is
sort of like this--
the Millennium
generation's cigarettes.
I think we're just at
the tip of the iceberg
as far as how terrible
lack of sleep is for us.
And honestly, it might even
eclipse the value of diet
in certain circumstances.
So when we don't sleep,
we know that the brain
shrinks over time.
We're not producing new neurons.
And our brain is shrinking.
We also have mass
produced growling,
which is a hunger hormone.
So that's why you
stuff your face
after you pull an all-nighter.
And you feel terrible.
Your mood is depressed.
You can't produce enough
serotonin, for example.
Meanwhile, when you
exercise, we know
that your brain gets bigger.
People who exercise
literally have larger brains.
And more specifically,
a bigger hippocampus,
which is the memory
center of the brain.
So you have a better memory if
you go for a run twice a week.
And that's it.
So I'd be happy to chat about--
I don't know what
your guy's experience
is with all this information.
I'm so in the weeds,
that it's hard to know
what I knew or
didn't know before,
or what I thought about or
didn't think about before.
Because I think about
this all the time.
But I'd be happy to chat about
any of that, or about the food
business, or whatever.
AUDIENCE: What's your take on
nootropics and Alpha Brain?
WILL NITZE: I've
tried alpha brain.
I'm a huge Joe Rogan fan.
I listen to Joe Rogan
Experience all the time.
That's the thing about
this whole lifestyle.
You get into the whole
quantified self, what's
my glucose, and all that stuff.
It becomes addicting.
You start listening to
eight podcasts at once.
Alpha Brain is an
interesting one.
I don't know a ton about it.
Although, it was a lot more
sugary than I wanted it to be.
The thing about
nootropics is, which
for people who don't
know about nootropics,
nootropics is anything that
makes your brain work better.
So caffeine is a basic
example of a nootropic
that we all know.
But there's also like a bunch
of crazy stuff you can eat
and you can't pronounce.
I think it's really
early days in terms
of what the downstream impact of
taking nootropics all the time
is.
Because it's
actually pretty new.
And it's not even really
on the east coast.
It's like there are
these pockets of people
who are really into nootropics.
How can I hack my
brain to work better.
I mean to the extent
that people are micro
dosing on LSD in Silicon
Valley to get more creative.
Apparently it works.
So I don't know.
But to me, the big
question mark is what's
the downstream impact of that.
I don't know.
What happens when you micro
dose on LSD for 10 years?
Maybe it's something not great.
But it's probably pretty
cool for 10 years.
You probably do a
lot of creative work.
And it's the same deal with
like Adderall, or Ritalin,
or whatever.
We don't really know
the downstream impact
when people start taking
it in kindergarten when
they're like 80.
We don't have the data.
But I'm very
interested about it.
I tested all that
stuff out on my--
not the LSD.
I test out nootropics
pretty regularly
and it's fun to see
how your body reacts.
Because it's like
you're not going
to kill yourself by trying
something once or twice.
But we're just at the
beginning of that.
That's going to
explode in my opinion.
AUDIENCE: Follow-up question,
how does your product,
and what's in it, differ
from what's in a nootropic?
WILL NITZE: So what we're trying
to do is basically two things.
So at a basic level,
flip the carb-fat ratio.
So how do we make it low
glycemic, physically keto
friendly.
If you're too don't you keto,
how do we minimize the blood
sugar impact.
That's like a baseline.
Then I get back to the whole
culture and Instagram thing.
Then we also try and layer
on six different things
that help you in other ways.
So a lot of them are health
elements, like Omega 3s,
you're not going
to get jacked up
if you eat a lot of fish oil.
And frankly, that's why
people don't regularly
eat it that much,
because you don't get
an immediate feedback with it.
It's like yeah, I think
this is going to be
good for my brain in 10 years.
And then you forget to
take it the next day.
But the reality is that,
then, you should be taking it.
So some are health related.
Some are more
neurogenesis related.
Like Lion's Mane, for example.
We're still young, in
terms of studies on that.
Lion's Mane is this
mushroom that helps you--
it makes you sharper.
I mean, anecdotally,
I would try it.
It helps you grow neurons.
So it helps expand your synaptic
connections in your brain.
So the stuff that
we layer on is not--
I mean, it's like a
2.49 nutrition bar.
So you have to treat it as such.
But our goal is how do
you eliminate the crash,
put a bunch of brain
healthy things in it,
energize the brain.
It's not like having a Red Bull.
Because the only-- there
are no biological shortcuts.
That's one of my favorite
lines, which I think is true.
When you do pound a Red
Bull, that's the only way
to rapidly up here--
or even Adderall, or whatever
shortcut people take--
you will rapidly
up your cognition,
speed, processing
time, et cetera.
But again, there's no
biological free lunch.
You're going to come
down after that,
just like you did when you drank
a Coke or ate a bunch of pizza,
or whatever the case may be.
So that's what we try to do,
is on a more subtle basis,
take out the crash, take
out the glycemic load,
and layer on things
that help your brain
in a variety of ways.
AUDIENCE: How do you determine
what's healthy fat level
that people should be intaking?
Because as someone
trying to go towards more
of a fat heavy diet,
as I'm starting
to drink Bulletproof
coffee and stuff.
I'm slowly, over
time, be like I'm
afraid I'm just going to
be getting fat and not--
so how do you determine
what levels of fat you
should be intaking, and also--
WILL NITZE: You can weigh
yourself every couple of weeks.
That's one way.
I was way into the
Bulletproof coffee thing too.
I was like so, I totally
drank the Kool-Aid.
I was like, this is so awesome.
It is awesome in some ways.
It knocks out your
hunger in the morning.
When you're eating, basically
what Bulletproof coffee is,
you get what's called
medium chain triglycerides,
or saturated fats,
which a lot of people,
it's like a four letter
word in a lot of circles.
But they're generally
accepted to be like the best
saturated fats you can eat.
What that does is,
it goes in your liver
and breaks down
into these things
called ketone bodies, which
is the only other brain
fuel, other than glucose, that
your brain can survive on.
When you fast, for example, the
way you survive is your body
turns fat into ketones.
Your body is literally
burning off fat, not glucose.
That's how you don't die
when you don't eat food.
But I think the jury's
still out on what
the right balance of fat is.
Like if you're a keto
fanatic, you've got all day.
80% of your diet should be fat.
You should eat
virtually zero carbs.
And you shouldn't even
really be counting calories,
because the whole calories
in, calories out thing
has been pretty much debunked.
So my perspective is the proof
is kind of in the pudding.
I would experiment and
try different levels.
Because again, everyone's
body reacts differently
to different levels of fat.
But like for me,
I've experimented
with a lot of ratios
and found what
I can eat so that I don't
get tired till like 7 PM
as the goal.
And I don't gain
weight, the other goal.
So I don't know.
That's not a very good answer.
But I would pick some
certain benchmarks.
And then just start gathering
data on how your body reacts.
It's different if you're
paleo, or keto, or whole 30.
AUDIENCE: Do you still
drink Bulletproof coffee?
WILL NITZE:
Sometimes, sometimes.
I don't eat breakfast.
I do fast in the morning.
I'm doing this 16-8
protocol, where you only
eat during eight
hours of the day,
fast until-- you eat at
like noon and then 7:30.
And then you just don't
eat the rest of the day.
Well, I kind of cheat, because I
do drink coffee in the morning.
But I'm not too
worried about that.
But yeah, I'm testing
that out on myself.
And that's been-- for a while I
needed some saturated fats just
to knock out my hunger.
But now I just kind
of power through it.
Bullet's worked well for me.
It's kind of expensive too.
So do you want to spend
that much every morning?
I don't know, maybe you do.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about your research and testing
process.
I know that you mentioned,
it's really hard
to figure out if what
the experts are saying
is actually true.
And then on the
other hand, there's
like a lot of new
information coming out
with all these new fad diets
or different products that
are coming out.
So how do you figure
out what's necessarily
the source of truth for you?
And how do you test that?
Is it just on yourself?
Or is it among you
and your friends?
How do you get that data
and test it [INAUDIBLE]??
WILL NITZE: For me,
also, I'm not an expert.
I'm just some guy who is
really interested in it.
So you shouldn't take my
word as gospel either.
But for me, I think it all
starts with anecdotal evidence.
So you know you body
better than anyone.
And as you start messing
with different ratios,
you'll find out what
works best for you.
So again, there's no
platitude that I can give you
where it's like
this is the ratio
and I'm tying that to
these four studies.
There's some high level stuff.
If you look at
longitudinal studies,
people who ate a ton
of fat did better
than people who
ate a ton of carbs.
But their genetic makeup
is different than yours.
And so there are ways to
get quantitative about it.
Some people get really into it
and track their blood glucose.
When you get your
annual physical,
you can see your
triglyceride level, basically
the fat in your blood.
So that's why it's hard.
You have to-- there
is no right answer.
There are certain
things we know are bad.
Everyone agrees sugar is bad.
That's not a debate anymore.
The only reason
people didn't agree
on that is because the sugar
lobby basically covered up
a bunch of evidence decades ago.
But anyway, we all
agree on some things--
sugar and fat.
There's these middle
ground saturated fats--
literally you ask
half of doctors,
and they'll say the
opposite saying things.
They'll say, well,
don't eat a ton of it,
but really there's
no correlation
with long-term heart failure.
And the next one
will be like, do not
eat that, you're going
to die in 20 years.
So it's like who do
you-- if you move
from one general
practitioner to another,
you get the opposite
advice, so to the extent
you're interested
in gathering data
on your own anecdotal
diet, and follow
broad based dietary guidelines,
like eat more fat than carbs.
And then there's
just baseline stuff.
Just stop eating sugar.
OK, you wrap your
burrito and go,
well, I'm not going to take
the wrap off my burrito,
I'm just going to
eat my burrito.
I don't think you need to
get too militant about it.
See what works for you.
That's my best
answer to that one.
AUDIENCE: So can you
talk a little bit
about the journey of
going into the bar market,
being like that it's
pretty saturated
and there's a lot of big
products in the market.
What's been your experience?
Why did you choose to
just jump into that?
And then what challenges
are you currently facing
with maybe getting into
stores and selling products?
WILL NITZE: The bar--
I thought of it from a
very simplistic standpoint.
I was like what mediums
of food or bev mediums
allow you to take 10
different things and jam them
into one small serving size.
Basically only the bar medium.
There's like no other medium
you can really do that with.
So there's that reality.
Then it's a huge growing market
that my generation happens
to eat a lot of.
And it happens to be able
to sustain a lot of brands
and still allow them to grow.
I almost didn't even--
my outlook has always
been I'd rather
get into a competitive field,
where there's guaranteed
demand, than try
and fabricate demand
with hopes of a moonshot
success on the other end.
So I'm not trying to do
an Airbnb and [INAUDIBLE]
or $40 billion, or
whatever they're worth.
I don't want to go where
I know there's demand.
And then I want to
try and out-compete
everyone who's there.
Because honestly, then my
destiny is more in my own hands
than if I was trying
to fabricate demand.
The bar market is
incredibly tough.
I think people,
I think there are
ways you can make it
less tough by going where
other people aren't going.
So things like
e-commerce have totally
changed the game for
not just the bar market,
but any food that ships
relatively cheaply
and have a long shelf life.
You're kind of out of luck if
you make Kombucha, [INAUDIBLE]
online.
But if you sell a
bar, well people never
used to buy them five
years ago, and now they're
buying it by five
boxes at a time.
You get paid now,
rather than 60 days.
And you own that customer.
Your website, you're
the only product there.
I think the traditional
route is incredibly tough.
It requires a lot of money.
If you want to get
into Whole Foods,
no one knows who you are.
You're one of 100 products.
Why would anyone ever pick you,
unless you have a hot pink bar.
Which isn't a bad idea.
I considered that.
But you're going to have to hire
a bunch of people to sample it.
And there's capital
costs, there's time costs.
There's just a dozen headaches.
Whereas, the cool
reality now is,
you can go find all
those customers online.
And then go to Whole
Foods in six months,
and say, hey, 5,000 of
your customers in Boston
are buying the product.
You probably want to carry us.
So that's kind of how
we're approaching it.
But I also think we
want to frame ourselves
not as a bar company, but more
as a brain nutrition company.
The bar happens to be the
first medium we're starting in.
It's certainly not the last.
I think it would be cool to make
Opus oatmeal, or single serve,
add hot water kind of thing.
I'm fascinated by the
cream coffee market.
If we frame ourselves
as a bar, we really
hamstringing our outlook.
Whereas, our goal, we're
a brain health company
that happens to sell bars.
It's fine to be a bar company
It's just not as
interesting to me.
And I think people like latch on
to that ethos a little bit more
readily than, hey, this is
like fruits and nuts crammed
together in a package.
But that's just my guess.
AUDIENCE: So you
were in college.
You studied psychology
and government?
WILL NITZE: Government,
psychology and neuroscience,
yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
WILL NITZE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So when you were
going through and thinking
about this idea, did
you have a lot of people
that would say, what do
you know about nutrition,
or did you question
on your own, am I
qualified enough to be talking
about nutrition to people?
And where did you
learn all these things?
Reading?
WILL NITZE: Yeah, I
don't think you ever
get rid of imposter
syndrome, by the way.
I've listened to a lot of
self-help type podcasts.
Apparently, all of the
highest performers still--
Jerry Seinfeld still
gets imposter syndrome.
You never feel like
you really should
be the guy or gal talking
about whatever topic it is.
That being said, I think a
total crutch for people to say,
well, you didn't
go to med school.
The guy who founded Bulletproof
coffee, for example,
gets this all the time.
He's not a PhD.
He didn't go to Med school.
But all this guy
does, Dave Asprey,
is research this stuff and
self test it, and test it
with his friends.
It's like, who are you
going to trust, someone
who went to med school 30
years ago, when we like
had totally outdated perceptions
of what is good for the body
and then talked zero
about nutrition?
Or some guy who lives
it, researchers it,
puts it in his own body?
I would take the
latter in that case.
But it's not to say that
it's not a valid argument.
It's like why should I listen--
that's why I say,
I'm not a doctor.
I'm not a nutritionist.
I happen to voraciously
research this stuff,
and live it, and test it,
and keep up on the latest
and greatest research myself.
But I'm not a PhD.
So yeah, you do get
that quite a bit.
What's nice is, you can latch
on to people who do have letters
after their name.
OK, don't take my word for it.
Go look at-- on our website,
we list 50 cited sources.
OK, don't take my word for it.
Go check out those 50 sites,
form your own opinion.
I aggregated them for
you and digested them.
But ultimately, you go listen
to people who do have degrees
or what have you.
Actually that's probably
the better way to do it.
I would start with that part.
AUDIENCE: Who do you feel
as though are your biggest
competitors?
There's not a lot of people
in the functional brain space.
So who would you say
is your competitors?
WILL NITZE: Honestly,
it's like other--
again, the tricky
thing is there's not
that many people going out
looking for a product--
we try and hook people in
a number of different ways.
Maybe they're keto.
So let's make sure
we're keto compliant.
Maybe they're paleo.
Let's make sure we're paleo.
Maybe they're vegan.
Let's make sure we're vegan.
I think the way
you hook them is--
so in those capacities,
our competitors
are other things of that nature.
So of like for keto, it
might be a Quest bar.
For vegan, maybe
it's a Lara bar.
Paleo, maybe it's an RX bar.
So you get a lot
of that, where it's
like I'm looking for a
product for this reason.
And now we're competing
with these people,
because that's
how they found us.
So at a certain level,
there's a market
that happens to share
dynamics that we have.
But then, there
are people who are
interested-- let's say
it's a senior citizen who's
terrified of cognitive decline.
Well now, are
competition-- and actually,
that's like a huge space for us.
Because now you have a mandate.
They're terrified-- nothing
drives action like fear.
And so competition there
is like Hills, Prevagen.
It could be a whole
host of things.
Whatever other solutions
to that problem is.
Maybe it's nothing.
Or a novel solution to that.
Again, we don't want to become
a nootrocutical or medicine,
we're again, a
2.49 nutrition bar.
But we get a lot of interest
from people for that reason.
So I'd say top competitors is
really just other bars that
have shared characteristics.
AUDIENCE: Who's your
target market then?
WILL NITZE: That's a
very good question.
So we think all the
time about that.
The way you speak to a
millennial and my grandmother
is very different.
They care about
different things.
They want to be
messaged to definitely.
They both could be
an awesome demo.
Millennials because
they eat a lot of bars.
Older folks, because they care
a lot more about brain health
and have a lot more money.
We're starting more so
at the Millennial group,
because it's easier and cheaper
to acquire them as customers.
They go on Facebook
and Instagram more.
They eat more bars.
But we're still
thinking that through.
The jury's not out on that.
Once we get more
data, it honestly
could-- because I
think the lifetime
value of older folks who are
more expensive to acquire,
is way, way greater, because
they're buying every month.
It's almost like
a daily vitamin.
AUDIENCE: What have you found
your most successful marketing
to be?
[INAUDIBLE] marketing or
would Facebook be better?
WILL NITZE: I'm dipping my
toes in AdWords a little bit.
AUDIENCE: Nice.
WILL NITZE: But again, we
don't have a ton of data yet.
We like launched our
website a month ago.
Yeah, we're super new.
So we're getting a lot of data.
We had a weird trajectory,
where we did crowd funding
and we sold like
$90,000 worth of bars.
Realized we wanted to
tweak a number of things,
didn't sell for
like four months.
And then we went live
on a website and Amazon.
We're really still
acquiring data.
And most of our data came back
from the crowdfunding thing,
which is weird.
Because people convert
differently on a kickstarter
than they do on
whatever dot com.
And they [INAUDIBLE]
an e-commerce setting.
We're trying everything, like
Facebook, Pinterest, AdWords.
Even some guerrilla
marketing stuff.
I put a massive decal
on the back of my car.
It's pretty hideous looking, but
I've got like five exclamation
marks.
I mean we're willing
to try anything
as long as it provides a ROI.
We're still in the infancy
and testing all that.
AUDIENCE: Well,
thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]